só tenho fausto soltani que é um
diminutivo de tatiana que o nome russo
que quer dizer rebelde
eu tenho maria que não usa busca
santidade mas eu digo pra vocês que tá
difícil
eu tenho um falso que eu uso quer dizer
um nome francês quer dizer luxo e
ostentação ao uso
eu tenho da silva no final que não uso o
negro quando chegava como mercadoria
nesse país
ele recebia um dar o de oliveira de
souza isso queria dizer que essa peça
era de alguém como fui contratada pela
família de ninguém então eu também uso
eu só tenho fausto
eu sou a primeira da minha família que
chegou à universidade e eu tenho muito
orgulho de dizer pra vocês que
influencia a segunda então hoje nós
temos engenheiros nós temos médicos nós
temos pianista e acabei de descobrir que
o pianista que vai terminar o evento é o
meu sobrinho
então eu tenho muito orgulho
eu sou educadora e sempre ouvi na minha
casa que ética e valores são muito
importantes e aí conta a educadora eu
acato atuação eu acabei assumindo a
direção de algumas escolas
cheguei a uma escola que é o que é esse
caso que eu quero contar pra vocês
cheguei a uma escola que não tinha
banheiro não tinha janela não tinha nada
só tinha um concreto não tinha projeto
pedagógico 286 alunos não tinha
banheiros chuveiros todos quebrados em
alimentação apesar de horário integral e
aí eu fui fazer o que eu sei fazer
reestruturar essa escola física
pedagógica e recreativa cultural
pedagógica gastronômica eu erro no seu
nei essa escola
nós chegamos a um crescimento não aprova
institucional um crescimento de 286%
numa prova excepcional nós fomos os
melhores em língua portuguesa e
matemática dentro de três anos
mas eu fui convidada a fazer por menos e
aí eu fico muito emocionada porque ainda
é muito difícil pra mim eu não sei fazer
por menos e aí eu briguei eu eu esperei
eu falei pra todo mundo
bom eu tô exonerada em dez anos sem
matrícula está na justiça o processo
aliás faz 11 anos esse ano fez agora em
janeiro
e aí eu entrei no processo de depressão
eu fiquei dentro da minha casa durante
quatro anos e nesse período eu voltei
pra dentro da minha comunidade e comecei
a encontrar a minha comunidade e aí
nesse reencontro um dia eu fui numa casa
de uma amiga para conversar e ela estava
fazendo
montando uma blusa pedaço por pedaço e
talho retalho construindo uma blusa de
uma beleza incrível tudo milimétrico
tudo muito bem construído e ela ganhou
cinco reais por essa blusa e ela
construiu 200 dessas blusas e eu vi essa
mesma blusa custam r$100 e aí nesse dia
eu fiquei boa nesse dia descobrir como é
que eu ia resolver a vida delas que não
era so essas donas chefes de família na
minha comunidade precisava também que
eram outras chefe de família as
costureiras e eu também precisava me
reconstruir e aí eu fui aí eu fui
aprender e eu fui me qualificar porque é
capacitado eu já sou eu fui me
qualificar e aí eu fui capacitação em
empreendedorismo gestão de negócio a
negócio social pesquisa de moda história
da áfrica gênero e poder
e aí eu fui das comunidades
e aí eu fui complexo do chapadão que eu
falei pra vocês como lá e aí eu fui pra
uma das três comunidades eu fui para
manguinhos eu fui pra contagem eu fui
pra niterói onde tem comunidade que me
chamo eu estou junto com as mulheres
e aí depois de um ano passado teve um
encontro importantíssimo de mulheres que
transforma o mundo e houve um processo
seletivo uma chamada um edital público e
nesse edital públicos entre 14 mulheres
foram contempladas fomos para uma
formação porque eu fui também contemplou
quando eu cheguei na porta
as mulheres estavam eu cheguei atrasada
e aí quando eu cheguei às mulheres já
estavam todas na porta quando eu cheguei
todo mundo começou a bater palmas você
que vai capacitar foi não gente eu
também isso vim fazer a comercialização
eu também tô aqui e aí eu percebi que 31
uma de 104 dessas mulheres tinham sido
minhas alunas e aí quando eu a gente
começou a conversar eu percebi que mais
30 dessas mulheres eram as minhas amigas
de luta de comercialização de trabalho
na rua e aí pela primeira vez depois
desse tempo eu olhei falei 'eu movimento
a roda eu sou fausto e aí as coisas
começaram a correr
[Aplausos]
eu tenho uma amiga que se chama é
cláudio de paula ea niacina são gestores
de projetos sociais
elas me fizeram seguinte pergunta tânia
nós temos sete meninas que foram
retiradas da sua família por conta de
violência doméstica e elas estão num
abrigo e elas são de 14 e 17 anos quando
elas saírem de lá no dia seguinte que
eles fizerem 18 elas vão pra rua e eu
não sei se vocês sabem mas elas saem sem
direito a nada simplesmente abriu a
porta elas vão embora e aí a gente
começou a fazer um trabalho com elas de
reestruturação e aí a gente partiu do
conceito do jeans
aí você me pergunta por que o jeans
porque o jeans ele o despojado ele o
glamoroso todo mundo quer usar porque
ele é o mais democrático
a minha neta de sete anos usa minha mãe
de 80 anos usa mas ele depois que cair
no desuso você joga no lixo
você não quer saber mais ele é um lixo
ele vai para o aterro sanitário
mas ele já foi o glamoroso ele já usou
muita água dessa natureza para que ele
fosse feito e aí o que nós fizemos
a gente partiu do conceito do dia junto
com elas e aí a gente desmontou
reconstruir um ea gente fez de novo
junto com elas
o jeans e aí a gente juntou tecidos que
nós recebemos doação e estudo de
materiais porque as pessoas normais acho
que é lixo a gente transformou tudo isso
em arte ea gente foi montando esse jeans
ea gente deu uma outra cara e se diz ao
mesmo tempo que a gente deu a essas
meninas e aí a gente juntou à arte
a gente juntou poder a gente juntou cor
a gente deu vida a gente deu uma outra
cara e se diz
e aí a gente montou uma coleção que a
gente chama o divino que habita em nós
ea gente desfilou na casa frança-brasil
agente desfilou e na pavuna na lona
cultural agente desfilou em niterói a
gente desfilou pelo rio de janeiro e aí
a gente ensinou liberdade
e aí o que eu venho contar pra vocês é
que ano passado o consultor me perguntou
tânia o que você faz eu falei pra eu
faço roupa
ele falou eu acho que é muito mais do
que
eu acho que é educação e poder
eu acho que a liberdade capacidade
eu acho que é empoderamento
somos um novo projeto de uma comunidade
de niterói
somos aqui estudantes de circo de teatro
de dança de de música de dança nós tem
até produtores gente
eu quero dizer para vocês que eu sou
tânia fausto filha de lourdes rosa pedro
nolasco mãe da quinta que lá a voz da
pérola é um ovo mundo eu movimento eu em
poder pessoas que eu sou isso
[Aplausos]